tonight on the new reality a little note
to people that go to the grocery store
supply and demand don't lose faith in
the food chain
it just needs a little bit of fixing
tracing our future we tend to be
very slow adopters of any new technology
like that this could be a good
opportunity for us to be a bit bolder
survival of the fittest just before i
got here i was running
to complete a marathon next year and now
i can't even
get up without losing my breath pregnant
in a pandemic the midwives wearing masks
there's no one else in the waiting room
if i get covered now i won't be able to
be there for the birth of my child
and rising to the challenge it can be
like kind of an emotional roller coaster
oh it's all about the crust isn't it
[Music]
hello i'm donna friesen we've all had
our lives disrupted in ways we never
expected
and this pandemic has made us consider
more deeply many
things in our lives we used to take for
granted the comfort of
hugging your friends the joy of dinner
out in a restaurant
and the steady supply of an abundance of
food
those who work the land plant the crops
harvest
the fields raise the animals catch the
fish
they keep the world fed and we're
accustomed to getting what we want
when we want it we always assume the
food producers will be there and that
shelves will be stocked with food from
all over the world
this pandemic has exposed the
vulnerabilities of our food supply chain
what happens when workers get sick and
when processing plants close down
when migrant workers no longer show up
david aiken looks at the impact
[Music]
southern alberta cattle country to me
there's not a prettier place in the
world we're right on the edge of the
foothills
bob lowe and his family have been on
these grasslands
for more than a hundred years i guess
cattle are kind of in
in my blood both sides of the family
have been in the cattle business since
before the turn of the century at times
have rarely been as tough
low and other beef cattle ranchers are
running out of room on their farms
the problem the handful of meat packing
facilities that process the country's
beef
are running well under capacity as those
plants struggle to keep their workforces
free of covet 19.
yep nope that's that's the bottleneck
the cargill plant just up the road from
lowe's ranch
has been the most high profile processor
to run into trouble
but there's similar issues for beef
ranchers hog farmers and
poultry growers all across the country
animals that should have been shipped to
market weeks ago
continue to grow and continue to cost
thousands of dollars every day to feed
low made it through the bsc or mad cow
crisis of the early 2000s but
this crisis is one for the ages i think
mentally it's probably worse
after mad cow hit 27 000
bee farmers packed it in and 5 million
acres of grassland pasture
disappeared sold to developers or put to
other uses
and that crisis was a relatively simple
one to fix
canada just had to get its beef back to
foreign markets
this thing it's global in nature for one
thing so
you know half of our production goes out
of country
but this is affecting those those other
countries too so
what that's going to do in the end we
don't really know
i mean we've got demand for our product
is there
can it get there we have no idea
[Music]
on the other side of the country in the
outport of bay bulls just south of st
john's jason sullivan readies his
atlantic outlaw
for the crab fishery that's about to
open i fished in crab about
i guess half an hour like since i'm a
kid but you know
full time in the last 20 years those who
farm the sea
are also facing stiff economic headwinds
the atlantic outlaw can hold thirty
thousand pounds of crab
that would have fetched as much as six
bucks a pound before the pandemic
the crab is a high-end product sold to
casinos cruise ships restaurants
markets that have all crashed now
sullivan might get
three bucks a pound then you got your
bait cost which is at
250 a pound which is so the price of
bait is nearly as much as we're getting
for
for the crab we're catching then there's
the cost of fuel
food mortgage on the boat for some
fishermen
it might not even pay to put their boats
in the water this year
and meanwhile there's the challenge of
keeping fishing crews safe from coven
19.
sleeping quarters for eight are below
decks
and it's mighty snug certainly not the
ritz carlton
and the galley for sullivan's crew well
it's a tight squeeze if everyone's at
the table at once
it's just like a little camper really
health authorities have issued some
guidelines
for fishermen it's not even practical
even to have these rules for us
if you know they don't work it's just
impossible to do what
the distance on a boat sullivan says
other suggestions were absurd
and it was kind of embarrassing by to be
honest with you i mean like don't share
the same toothbrush and stuff like that
and i mean my god i mean
you know we are living in aurora
newfoundland but you know we might have
the woods but we didn't need the bushes
we don't we don't we don't share the
same toothbrushes or anything in general
so i don't know why
you know but that's the kind of stuff
that they came out with
[Music]
back on land at the country's vegetable
and fruit farms
the safety challenge is a bit more
manageable mass gloves and sanitization
but these farmers have a different
problem a labor
shortage nick de gerolimo and his family
have been growing veggies and herbs
since the early 1960s it's it's it's a
life okay
you've done this your whole life like my
brother and i my
and my son and my dad still he's 95
he's still on the property and we
we work seven days a week okay even
christmas day i show up here
but during planting season that's right
now
and during harvesting diedralmo and his
family
cannot do it all themselves they bring
in highly trained workers
from mexico we need them that's all
there is to it we can't not get
canadians to do
the work on a continuous basis normally
more than 25
000 temporary foreign workers help
canada's farmers every year
most come from mexico but also from
caribbean and other latin american
countries
they do jobs that canadians will not do
or
cannot do everybody says you're getting
unskilled labor but they're not
unskilled labor because they've been
coming here
doing the same jobs for years okay and
coming back to the same farms
and they know how to pick an apple and
how to treat it gently they know how to
pick a berry without squeezing it they
know how to pick a tomato without
sticking their fingernails in
this is ishmael's eighth year working
for nick
he's a good person good boss
it's a good good friend but this year
several thousand of those vital
agricultural workers
just are not coming to canada because of
the pandemic and those that did come
had to be quarantined for 14 days at the
expense
of their employers the shortage of
agricultural workers
and their delay in getting to canada
means that some
crops simply did not get planted i think
there's going to be a shortage
of fresh fruits and vegetables in in the
fog
[Music]
meanwhile back at the ranch bob lowe
tries to put it all in perspective
a little note to our customers to
the people that go to the grocery store
and buy our product
it's perfectly safe we've got a problem
getting it to you
but that'll be fixed and and
don't lose faith in the in the food
chain
it's still there it just needs a little
bit of fixing
getting things fixed getting back to
normal and reopening the economy
will require three key things more
testing
to catch outbreaks before they get out
of control contact tracing to identify
anyone an infected person came in
contact with
and isolation to break the chain of
transmission
test trace isolate is the mantra and
it's the tracing part where the right to
individual privacy collides with the
need to protect public health
south korea has led the world in
successful contact tracing
as jeff semple explains it's required
some trade-offs
not everyone is comfortable making
south korea offers a glimpse of a
brighter future
crowds returning to amusement parks
the movies even the airport as though
the country just woke up
from a strange dream
it feels great to be out with my family
he says we are still cautious
but it looks like the containment
efforts are going well
south korea was one of the first and
hardest hit countries by the kovid 19
pandemic
but after two months of strict social
distancing on wednesday
it relaxed the rules and since then
there have been almost
no new cases the government had
prepared i think that's the most
important thing dr jerome kim is the
head of the international vaccine
institute
he points to his country's outbreak of
another coronavirus
mers in 2015 that spurred the government
to introduce new
emergency powers allowing it to harness
credit card records and smartphone gps
locations to track and retrace the
movements
of covid19 patients although you're
tracked you're still anonymous
and it's really the government and and
the people who might have been exposed
to who find out
the anonymized data is used to identify
hot spots
and in smartphone apps to alert users
about cases
nearby really don't do well with this
um oops so that's the alarm during our
interview
lee's own smartphone sounded an alarm
alerting him that a covid 19 patient had
visited his neighborhood bar
called king club zero at a specific time
if you had a fever of 37.5 and weren't
going to work and you knew that you'd
been at king club zero
um you know you'd go in for testing and
they piped they probably
would put you in isolation similar apps
have been deployed
in more than 25 countries from australia
to the uk
but what about canada we're ready to go
we have a product that can be deployed
in
a matter of days daniel lee's
vancouver-based company
pitched their contact tracing app to
several provinces
including ontario unfortunately we just
didn't see the traction on the public
sector side
for the most part canada is still doing
contact tracing
the old-fashioned way thank you very
much i appreciate that
health professionals and volunteers
calling a covid19 patient's contacts
one by one so that we can connect with
them
find out if any of them are symptomatic
and get them tested otherwise they need
to be isolating and that's the strategy
but that system is far from perfect
first i got the call
from the hospital telling me i got
positive
this vancouver actor tested positive and
says health officials asked him for a
list of his contacts
and then and then i told her what i've
been doing
went to the gas station but an employee
at that gas station told global news
they never received a call from public
health and had no idea a covid 19
patient had been there it's going to
require
many many many people to be able to
follow up with all of those positive
tests
and that's a part where i think we're
particularly vulnerable because no
public health unit has the
resources to do that right now a contact
tracing app
would automate that process but there's
a catch
most of the apps on offer require access
to a smartphone's gps location
allowing the government to track a
person's movements and sparking concerns
over privacy if you know that
as of tomorrow the government
has a trace on everywhere i've been and
all the people i've come in contact with
you may not want to live in a country
like that for a contact tracing
app to be effective studies suggest at
least 60 percent of the population
needs to opt in if you have large swaths
of canada that look at these
applications with suspicion
that look at these apps as injurious to
their way of living
they will not use them but a solution
may be
in sight google and apple are now
building a framework that will allow
contact tracing apps on their devices to
use bluetooth technology
the bluetooth signal would locate other
phones nearby that are running the same
app
so say you'd visited a restaurant and
the person at the table next to you were
to test positive
you'd receive an alert but your data
would be encrypted
and never leave your phone unless you
tested positive
and consented apple has walked me
through on two occasions
all of what they've done in terms of the
tech
and the privacy presenting features and
no geolocation data and everything
and so i can give my vote of confidence
to it
download a b trace together turn on your
bluetooth
some apps like the one released just
last week in alberta
already employ bluetooth technology but
without software support from the tech
giants
they've been plagued with problems
really i think most
serious app developers at the moment
have to wait until
google and apple implement their
technical infrastructure in their
smartphones
the google apple app support should be
ready later this month
but most governments in canada still
have not authorized any apps to use the
technology
health experts warn the longer the
weight the greater the risk
we tend to be very slow adopters of any
new technology like that we wait until
the rest of the world has done it and
then we gingerly put our toes into the
water
you know this could be a good
opportunity for us to be a bit bolder i
mean people
if they don't know by now they should
know that their location is being
tracked on their phone 24 7 and most
people have not turned off the
location switch
on their phone and it's used for all
sorts of things
right now typically for marketing hey if
it's used for marketing
uh using it for good to try to prevent
deaths seems like a more noble cause and
so why wouldn't we be okay with that
the more restrictions are lifted the
greater the need for contact tracing
and testing and experts warn canada is
currently
lacking in both
we keep hearing those most at risk from
covid19 are the elderly and that's true
but there are exceptions georges
larocque is a big
exception he's 43 years old six foot
three and fit
george larocque is a former nhl enforcer
for 12 seasons he was one of the
toughest guys on the ice
he does have asthma but he says he's the
kind of guy who rarely gets sick
and yet this is where he ended up in
early may
in a quebec hospital diagnosed with
covid19
just before i got here i was running uh
to complete a marathon next year
uh five six days a week ten kilometers
every day
and now i can't even get up
uh without losing my breath it's insane
i wake up in sweats all the time and
you know i'm not the only one fighting
this so don't feel sorry for myself it's
okay
with pneumonia in both lungs he spent
five days in the hospital and is now
recovering at home in self-isolation and
george larocque is feeling well enough
to talk to us today george
thanks for doing this did you ever for a
second imagine you'd be one of the
people who ended up in the hospital
with covid19 i actually thought it was
blown out of proportion
and i never thought i was going to get
it there's no way i
i thought it was only affecting older
people and
that if i was going to get it i was not
going to have any symptoms
well it came back and blew me right in
my face because i
end up in the hospital and brought me a
big piece of humility yeah well i know
you had trouble breathing
you had a fever tell us what it felt
like to go through
the symptoms well you know at the
beginning i had chills
and uh you know i was in bed i totally
wet my bed when i woke up in the morning
i was like what's going on my body i'm
never sick
and my breathing started to be a bit
hard and
i went to the hospital because it was
weird i didn't know i was feeling this
way
and i wanted to get checked because i
was delivering food to elderly people
and i'm like if i'm sick
i need to tell them so when i went to
the hospital they did an x-ray and then
they checked me out
and they were like oh we don't need to
do the test
your lungs are a bit a bit swollen so
they give me some cortisone pill they
sent me home
but then my swelling and my breathing
was getting worse and worse
and when you have asthma you're a bit a
bit worried when your breathing is a bit
harder because you wonder what's going
to happen
and you never want it to stop but then
the hospital calls me back and they said
the doctor made a mistake in your x-ray
and you have pneumonia
i'm like what so i end up going back to
the hospital on thursday and things
where
my brain was much harder and i was mad
when i was at the hospital i was like
listen
i need a test i need to tell the elderly
if i'm sick so they could go get checked
so they did a test and then they said
yes you have it and you have the ammonia
on your lungs and you plug me to the
oxygen that went through my nose just
take me back to the first time you went
to the hospital and you asked for a test
and they said no what reason did they
give you
they said that they didn't have enough
and they need to save them
and whether i have it or not it wasn't
important
i'm like yes and it's important because
there's elderly people that needs to
know my
status so the second time when i was so
mad and i asked for it
they were like well you know knowing
that they should have did it the first
time
i'm like so they didn't even agree with
the fact that they didn't do it the
first time it was so weird
but at least i'm happy that all the
elderly that was delivering food to they
all got tested
because i was positive and they were all
negative so that's a relief
but what do you think that the fact that
you didn't get a test initially that
there was this confusion
says about the sort of system in quebec
about testing people
the the system here is no good it's no
good
it makes zero sense me if i was
delivering food to elderly people it
means i'm
i'm doing a job that is essential if i
can't even get tested
so they could be safe what does it say
to others when i was at the hospital and
i was talking to the nurse
you know what they told me the nerves
that are going to war every single day
to help out
the people that are suffering from covet
they said george
we feel so bad because before we go home
we can't even get tested to know if
we're bringing the disease at home to
our family
do you have any idea where you picked it
up
yeah i do um when i was doing all the
grocery shopping
i had this bad habit every time i put my
hair back to touch my face
i always do that now i'm gonna have to
wear an elastic because when you go to
the grocery store
you wash your hand in your car and you
purell before you start driving but
i touch my face maybe 20 30 times before
i even
wash my hand because i'm always putting
my hair back like this
and when you touch it when you're
grabbing stuff it's the worst thing
and again i didn't think it was that
contagious
so i was doing it anyway but now i know
george if you uh
felt before like you were never going to
get this disease or if you did you
wouldn't get very sick
what message do you have now for people
who are your age have your fitness level
who might also
think that they're almost immune well
you know what i would say to them is
that
take this seriously and and if if not
for yourself
knowing that you're young you might
recover from it but from the people
around you because you don't know who
you're going to be in contact with
but maybe you'll be in contact with
somebody that the immune system is not
strong enough
maybe somebody that is recovering from
cancer and that's
what you have to think about still ahead
on the new reality
the rise of baking how old is your
starter
my starter what do you mean the
questions and answers about our new love
for bread making and not so easy green
killing it up there she's biking for two
what to expect when you're expecting
in a pandemic the midwives wearing masks
there's no one else in the waiting room
it just
had a totally different feel and up next
discovering a vaccine is one thing
making it is another
how will everyone who needs it get it
humankind has never faced a more urgent
task on a tight timeline
than defeating covid19 a vaccine is what
everyone is waiting for and counting on
to allow us to be in close contact with
each other again
but everyone will have to be vaccinated
more than 7 billion people and
ideally it will have to happen quickly
so we don't end up with some country's
economies back on track while others
wait
and continue to suffer so discovering a
vaccine
is the first challenge the second is
manufacturing it
i'm delighted to get the ball rolling
it was almost like a telethon the
european commission
mobilizes one billion euros
a virtual summit of world leaders
collaborating
to fund the creation and production of a
vaccine for covid19
it's humanity against the virus
we're in this together and together
we will prevail billions were promised
in three hours usually a vaccine takes
the bill and melinda gates foundation
alone committed 100 million dollars
coven 19 has reminded us that viruses
don't obey
borders or customs laws they don't care
about what nationality you are
absent though were the u.s and russia a
sign that not only is creating a vaccine
a massive challenge
so is the prospect of world leaders
fighting the pandemic
while fighting each other
we must share says germany's chancellor
universal access must be guaranteed says
the pope
in the race for a safe and effective
vaccine multiple horses are in the
running
more than 100 teams of researchers in at
least 21 countries
there is no guarantee of a winner if
there is
the whole world will cheer and then
every country will want the vaccine
immediately whoever creates it will
likely control it
the next step will be producing the
vaccines in
a sufficient number to inoculate
everyone or almost everyone that is
something that we are preparing already
in terms of manufacturing and production
capacity here in canada because we know
that
countries around the world will be
producing for their own citizens first
and
we need to be part of that as well the
scale of what's needed
is daunting more than seven billion
doses produced
and distributed i can't imagine there is
any
country in any country in the world with
a a production facility
that could turn out billions of doses in
a reasonable time frame
we have to figure out can we manufacture
it we have the vials we have the
syringes do we have the needles right
now the answer
is no plus not all vaccines are produced
the same way
the vaccine is the most likely solution
and
so great scientists are rushing to get
that done that's why bill gates the
biggest funder of vaccines in the world
is proposing spending billions to build
seven different factories
for the leading vaccine candidates if
one
is successful it can go straight to the
factory right away
the sooner the better there are 100
efforts but maybe 10 of those
should get the resources to build
factories and go full speed ahead
then the vaccine has to be carefully
packaged possibly refrigerated
and shipped all over the world
this is the world's largest vaccine
producer the serum institute of india
it rolls out more than 1.5 billion doses
of vaccine a year
it has signed on with a group of the
front runners for a covid19 vaccine
but has made it clear india will come
first
in the u.s johnson johnson has signed
partnerships
promising to deliver a billion doses of
a potential vaccine next year
elsewhere the sheer scale of the task
has brought pharma giants and rivals
together
glaxosmithkline and sanofi have united
aiming to produce hundreds of millions
of doses
but there have been signs too of
underhanded tactics
in march a german news report claimed
american president donald trump tried to
buy exclusive rights to a potential
vaccine
being developed by kurovac a leading
german biotech firm
the ceo abruptly left the company and
the company later insisted
there was no offer from trump and then
there's operation
warp speed the presidents made in
america planned to have at least 300
million doses of vaccine available
in the u.s by january we're going to
fast track it like you've never seen
before with china also
a front-runner in the race for a vaccine
comes deeper concerns the urge to hoard
might further flare tensions with the
u.s the contribution of china and the
united states
both to fight kovit 19 is in my opinion
absolutely essential the world already
knows the pitfalls of everyone chasing
the same
limited supply the shortage of personal
protective equipment
and the hoarding by some countries cost
thousands of lives
and it's led to a new awareness about
the need to be self-sufficient
and who's to say the same protectionist
impulses the frantic bidding wars
the overall erosion of trust won't
plague the infinitely more complicated
mission
to vaccinate it really depends on on
what the nature of the vaccine
is but no there are not a lot of places
in canada with with the capacity and to
ship
35 million doses in a reasonable time
frame is it's
just logistically and technically very
difficult
we're still learning about this virus
but if it's taught us anything
it's that an outbreak anywhere is a
threat
to everyone
it's never timely enough in an outbreak
session what i see what i
hear what i feel what i also feel myself
is that people
are doing that really the very best and
beyond
to to be as quick as possible
improvements in public health have been
one of the great triumphs of modern
times
life expectancy on average now is
greater than ever before
childhood mortality has dropped terrible
diseases
vanished and vaccines like the one for
polio
have been revolutionary that's another
lesson
jonah sulk who developed the polio
vaccine refused to patent it
who owns the patent on this vaccine well
the people i would say
there is no patent this is could you
patent the sun
it belonged he believed to the people if
a vaccine is discovered for covid19
the reality is not everyone will get it
at the same time
it could take months or years to produce
7 billion doses
and there will be many dilemmas
including who
should get it first dr seth berkley is
ceo of
gavi an international vaccine alliance
that works to bring
public and private sectors together to
create equal access to vaccines
he's a medical doctor and an
epidemiologist and dr berkley is in
geneva creating a safe and effective
vaccine is a big enough challenge
and we know many of the best scientists
in the world are working non-stop on
that right now
assuming we get one what about
manufacturing it does the capacity exist
right now
part of it depends by the time the
vaccine is ready is
who it will need to be used in and so
if we're talking about the entire
population of the world
it obviously also depends on is it one
dose two doses
what's the type of manufacturing it is
that's all going to affect how quickly
we can scale up
which is why today we need to prepare
for that and so
what we're trying to do is ask what's
the manufacturing capacity that exists
across the world now
how much of that is can be repurposed
because of course we don't want to stop
routine vaccines
in fact right now one of my greatest
battles is how to keep routine vaccines
going because
if we were to stop routine vaccines to
prevent coronavirus
cases for example for every death you'd
prevent from coronavirus you'd have 101
deaths
from existing vaccine preventable
diseases so we're trying to look at
what that capacity is and then of course
the next step will be
to try to make that capacity available
to whichever are the best vaccines
in the world so we can scale up rapidly
why is it important for wealthy
countries to make sure that developing
countries
also get the vaccine that's a great
question i mean you know
from one sense you can say it's a
humanitarian imperative
because we all are on this planet
together but there's also a
self-interest which is
we saw this virus was able to move from
a small
um community in wuhan um to
180 countries over the course of three
to four months
that shows how fast infectious diseases
can move
so if we want to protect our countries
our family we need to stop this disease
spread wherever it is in the world and
that's why we have to take a global
perspective
we know what happened with ventilators
and personal protection equipment the
competition for dwindling supplies
countries outbidding each other
could that play out again with a vaccine
that's why we have to start planning now
because if we don't plan if we don't
agree
if we don't have these discussions
that's exactly what will happen
and it's not just on the access to the
vaccine it's also the quality of the
science
science is global and what you want is a
situation
where the best science in the world gets
made available to everyone in the world
not the best science in
one country or the best in one company
you want us to be searching the world
for the best vaccines and making those
available and that's why we need global
cooperation
no vaccine has been made for any
coronavirus from the common cold to sars
can we be sure there will be one for
covet 19
well of course the answer is until we
have one we can't be certain
most of my vaccinologist friends um who
worked on sars and others feel that
this is a technically feasible vaccine
and that
we will be able to solve that problem
but of course what we don't know yet
is do you get long-term immunity to this
virus that's going to be an important
question
the seasonal coronavirus you don't and
you after a year you can get reinfected
with the same strain
but of course that's a mild upper
respiratory infection
this is a very severe infection and our
hope is that we're going to be able to
get
long and durable protection against this
virus but the only way to know that
is to do the science coming up
i just got back from my third week
pregnant during a pandemic
and if i get covered now i won't be able
to be there for the birth of my child
first-time parents facing up to fears
before the big day
on this mother's day there's lots of
virtual hugging going on
everyone is longing for the day when we
can get close again
for those women who are pregnant right
now motherhood is about to get
very real babies of course don't wait
around for a crisis to subside
what is it like to be expecting in the
midst of all of this
well we're following a couple who are
due to have their first baby
in just a few days they've been
documenting their journey
of what to expect when you were
expecting during a pandemic
i'm karine and i'm eli and we're having
a baby in the time of coronavirus
it's true we met four years ago while i
was out in vancouver for work
i was living in toronto she was living
in vancouver so we did the long distance
thing for a while
bouncing back and forth between the two
cities
a big part of our lives and our
relationship is traveling
and adventures whether it's camping in a
westy exploring new countries or just
going for a hike we love getting outside
and trying new things
so when we found out last fall we were
pregnant we were pretty pumped to embark
on this new adventure
we were in ontario at the time and
things started off
fairly normal
[Music]
doctor's visits this is what you look
like
in 19 weeks hanging out with friends and
family
we headed back west in january we even
went on a baby moon to palm springs
toured around on bikes hills on cruiser
bikes not so easy
green killing it up there she's fighting
for two
explored joshua tree lounge in the pools
life was good but after we got back
things started to change
pretty quickly the reality is that the
number of people affected by the virus
around the globe
keeps climbing coronavirus was becoming
more of a thing
and people were starting to talk about
it it started with little things like
no more high-fives at volleyball than an
environmental conference i was to attend
in vegas got cancelled
and the next thing you know things
started shutting down
i was really excited for my sister to
come visit in march but we had to cancel
her trip
questions started being raised about our
healthcare options as we entered the
third trimester
and our day-to-day shifted as everyone
started isolating can we go to the
hospital is the hospital even safe what
if we get sick can the baby get covered
can my mom steal our babies
what does this mean financially how long
is this going to last where do we go
from here
there are a lot of questions and to most
the answer was unknown
does it stress you out that i can't come
to the appointments
in person no the first time
definitely was a little bit more intense
because it was our first appointment
during covent so the midwives were
wearing masks
there was no one else in the waiting
room it just had a totally different
feel
but now that we've done it a few times
and you can still participate and call
in and ask questions and hear our
updates
it's okay so like everyone we had to
trust in the experts
stay at home and focus on what we can
control
like makeshift grocery masks i don't
have a real mask
so i'm using my ski mask to cover my
face just as an attempt
to make it a little bit safer i got my
hand sanitizer i got my lysol wipes
the reality is we're 39 weeks in and if
i get covered now i won't be able to be
there for the birth of my child
which would suck so ski masks up let's
get some peppers
and washing everything that came in the
house just in case
it'd be nice to have elias announce the
sex of the baby and cut the cord we
wrote our birth wish list
it'd be nice if we have a hospital berth
to be able to come back here quickly
yeah
in order to pull it sure we can do that
[Music]
we installed the car seats
dad life we tried to stay active with
workouts and going to the beach
our social life moved online we took our
own maternity phones
i started wrapping up work and we joined
an online group with other expecting
parents
i just got back from my 38-week
appointment we took a baby class online
and i joined our midwife appointments
from my phone
through it all we were blessed with love
and support from friends and family
they kept us grounded and helped us
celebrate this new chapter
a friend made us a quilt
my cousin steph made us a and loved ones
spoiled us with hand-me-downs and
thoughtful gifts
they even planned a surprise shower over
zoom
i did that
i heard someone say the other day we're
all in the same storm but we're in
different boats
and i think that is so true we've been
blessed with a healthy pregnancy
and because we are in bc at the moment
our birth options are
pretty stable we could still have our
midwives and our doula
and i can still attend the birth but for
many that's not the case
everybody's situation is different and
everyone handles things differently
this isn't really what i pictured for
the end of our pregnancy
there have been disappointments and
tears but at the end of the day we are
okay
and we have so much to be grateful for
we don't know what the future holds
especially during this pandemic things
could go totally sideways at a moment's
notice
but for now we're just going to try and
make the most of things
soak it all in because this baby will be
here
before we know it
next on the new reality it can be like
kind of an emotional roller coaster
rising to the challenge so this is what
i mean oh
nicely done how isolation is breeding
new bakers
in many canadian families
[Music]
staying home and staying inside means
many of us are discovering skills we
never knew we had
many of them in the kitchen for some
reason
baking bread has become a big thing
flour has been flying off the shelves
and is being kneaded into dough by
novice bakers across the country
our mike drolet is one of them and we
asked him to explore
what it is about bread and baking it
from scratch
that's become the perfect pandemic
pastime
there's something in the way bread makes
us feel
fresh out of the oven a pat of butter
melting in the first cut
studies have shown the aroma of fresh
bread makes us happy
kinder which isn't a bad thing
considering where the world is at right
now
even in defeat there's a certain
satisfaction
at having tried i've been doing this
since
like seven this morning the folding
thing
and it's still like this no doubt she
did some searches online
for baking she wouldn't be alone google
trends shows that by the first week of
april canadians were asking how to bake
ten times more than normal that's when
emily oven okay her last name was
actually hoven
began a popular thread called how to
make sourdough at the end of the world
which is clearly a bit dramatic but less
so when you hear her talk
about bread it can be like kind of an
emotional rollercoaster people don't get
like the
consistent rising that they're maybe
hoping for um
but usually if you just like show up for
it every day keep feeding it
it'll it'll be fine after a few weeks so
just keep going
and so many of us did with various
degrees of success for every
gold and crusty loaf there were 10 fails
like this
but slowly we started to get better at
it allowing home bakers like abten
azer paju to share the wealth but i
think it's actually helping me uh
uh become a bit more popular amongst my
friends because now
like i'll just do a big batch and put it
in like a bag for a friend and then
we'll just drop it off over the past
century homemade bread went from being a
staple to a luxury
let's face it who had the time to bake
before in many ways this pandemic has
created the perfect conditions
to try new things isolation has taken
away
so much yet it's given me two new family
members there's
magnus the pug and this
a 20 kilo bag of flour
anybody who's done any baking knows just
how glorious it is
and if i need to explain baking
ingredients most notably flour
sold out early and have been very slow
to get restocked
in fact we reached out to some
independent flour mills to talk about
demand
only one agreed to speak on the
condition of anonymity
seriously so we animated the
conversation
i can't handle any promotion right now
he told us i'm only filling sixty
percent of my orders i can't keep up
so you're running out of flour i asked
no
he said still stressed out i have enough
flour i'm running out of bags
and yet it's the run on yeast that has
led to the most confusing of
conversations
how old is your starter my starter
what do you mean the starter as baker
extraordinaire and
food network canada star anna olson
pointed out to me
is necessary for anybody who can't
procure yeast to make dough rise
it's flour water and the time to allow
it to ferment
and create a natural yeast that said the
bread i made with store-bought yeast
garnered rave reviews so this is what i
made
oh nicely done i'm impressed mike
my dutch oven loaf so painstakingly made
over
six hours of kneading and rising and
baking
has now been validated by none other
than anna olsen
oh it's all about the crust isn't it and
what she says about her craft
makes sense baking is a family affair
just as ingredients measured together
just so
can make the perfect cake getting the
right mix of anything in a bowl
is the recipe for a happy household
young families she says are asking her
about class songs pancakes
waffles and cookies it jumps up to
making french macaron making fondant
covered cake like your wife is doing
um it's it's that next level of decor so
there's a big leap
and even and if you've never baked
before
starting with french macaron will be a
bit of a challenge
one worth taking on provided the
ingredients are available
but i suspect more canadians today will
rise to the challenge
coming up sustaining the line
the growing cross-country support for
small businesses
and front line workers
[Music]
and finally an update to a story we
brought you a few weeks ago on the new
reality
it's about businesses helping local
restaurants stay afloat by teaming them
up with donors who cover the cost of
making meals
to feed frontline healthcare workers the
canadian group is called sustain the
line and
since our report aired they've had so
many offers from generous donors
they're now in 19 cities across the us
and canada
where it's truly a national effort
spanning halifax to fort mcmurray
sustain the line has helped 100
independent businesses stay alive
by helping them deliver more than ten
thousand meals
and this canadian group now has
international interest to expand their
work into berlin
rome paris london and other cities food
and generosity
obviously a powerful combination
well on this mother's day when all we
want to do is give our moms a hug
many are finding new ways to embrace
their mother
four siblings who live in different
places across canada have found a way
and
they've made it a treasured part of
their daily routine
thanks for watching
[Music]
my alarm goes off at 10 o'clock every
day so i phone her
pretty much every day at that time and
we usually play music
i feel very blessed because uh all four
kids are very loving
paul uh well he plays a guitar and sings
too
uh but mostly people talk about the
beautiful landscape in bc where he's
living lorraine my daughter
reads to me now traditions were being
honored again
she can't see to read it herself so i am
happy to read it for her
that's one little thing that i can do
for her right now
when i can't go visit her and bring her
her favorite foods that she likes
we whistle we whistle and
have a good chuckle over if you can get
a whistle out or not
i just want my mom to know that she's
cherished and the things that she's done
will
just live forever through
her kids and her grandkids i have a
dream
i will come true that you're
here with me i'm here